back to childhood what is happening that
makes us like we are well that initial
longing that i was talking about that i
believe we're all born with and i think
it's this blueprint to search for love
and i think that longing is for a
perfect love
but then we are searching for that
perfect love through imperfect people
and we're all imperfect and that's why
we name the podcast holy and human
because we are very realistic about the
human part of that equation where we
really start the work with holy love is
first recognizing where we've been
disappointed in love
and where love has wounded us because i
think we need to face those things first
it can be really
a common experience to start becoming
disenchanted with love and have wounds
come up have negative relationship
experiences or have parents that don't
emotionally reflect us and believe that
love itself is a compromise
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast thank you very much for tuning
in today on the show we have adam foley
and elisa romeo they are a married
couple who does family counseling
they're also authors
elisa is a licensed family therapist a
best-selling author adam is a healer and
a spiritual coach and i've known them
for a really long time i have
interviewed them before i read their
book meet your soul and then it happened
after so it was beautiful experience and
it's been really instrumental in my life
so they have a new book out and it's
called holy love it's been a labor of
love i've talked to them so many times
over the years of them developing it and
this is a book that's about really like
merging and getting to know yourself and
your soul
wholly as in h-o-l-y but wholly as in
whole w-h-o-l-e right like to be whole
that part of you needs to be
acknowledged so a lot of the
conversation had to do with when we sort
of uh fraction off when these parts of
us are not loved and or cultivated in
love and
um and so we talk about attachment
styles and where they come from and sort
of how they material materialize in your
life and i just think that's so
important um it's not about becoming
fully healed to be able to be in
relationship but it's about being
willing to heal and then and that the
beauty of relationships is that while a
lot of the the wounds are created in one
also the final healing is within one as
well and so
that can be with yourself but it can
definitely be with others
others are even better so i hope you
enjoy this conversation i it's
super educational as well as inspiring
so enjoy the show and of course please
hit the subscribe button if you like
what you hear and you want to hear more
of the pretty intense podcast
for those who don't know
you know i've come to your house i've
read your books i've interviewed you um
before this um to hear your love story
and i thought that one of the things
that i could do though right off the bat
that would be
a good like lead-in to because i want to
talk a lot about the book because
honestly like i just printed off the
chapter names and i'm like this is a
this is a good guide to conversation
because there's so many heavy hitters
within just the the chapter titles
themselves so i'm going to read the
first paragraph
of the introduction because i feel like
this is going to sort of lead
um
open the door for people to understand
the areas that will be
touched on in the book and and and
unpacked so here i go it's always funny
to read out it's always funny to read
out loud that's what we've been fighting
recording the audiobook where like
you get in your head a little bit you're
like wait what is this word do i even
know what this word is
it's looking good i'm not the only one
yeah
okay
all right okay the book is called holy
human
i'm sorry the book is called holy love
that's the podcast
which we had you on by the way and
people still are just like we love that
podcast with danica because you were so
articulate and um moving about how you
spoke with your connection to your soul
but we can
talk about that later or whatever
this one's about you so
um all right i'll try and be articulate
as i read this first paragraph
you may not realize it but your whole
life has been a crash course all of your
most important memories have been part
of a living syllabus
from the first moment you gazed into
your mother's eyes you've been front row
in class that horrible fight with your
childhood friend the crush at summer
camp your first kiss the first time
going further
we're all part of a curriculum your
first serious relationship the horrible
breakup the feeling of being utterly
alone and then ecstatic makeup sex were
all assignments good assignment
that was my words
the unexpected shock of betrayal and the
conscious decision to forgive were tests
from sitting bedside during the loss of
a loved one to witnessing the birth of
new life you've been learning delight
joy trauma contentment conflict have all
been incent have all been intensive
subjects during your immersion in love
101
i just think it's a great preface to
understand kind of the chunk of the book
being like about you your inner child
your experiences
and how this allows you to be able to
love yourself
and
receive love from others and learn how
to love
so
first off maybe even just starting like
with the title like where did i mean
you've got holy holy holy human as your
podcast um but this is called holy love
so let's just explain the title
yeah
you know it was an emotional experience
here and you read yeah
having that same experience like because
you know we've been in this little cave
writing and stuff and now it's like
coming out in the world and it's like
danica's reading your words that i the
way the book started was because i was
washing the dishes one day and adam
walked in he's like i'm just hearing
this kind of essay coming through and he
read that paragraph to me
and i was just like what's happening
this feels really powerful what's coming
through you and
i started tearing up and crying and i
looked at him and i was just like well i
guess we're writing a book
and i was not super excited about that
idea on an ego level because
just i know writing of books a lot of
time and a certain type of work and
exhaustion
as opposed to what we thought we were
doing which was just going to go
straight into online courses with our
mystery school so it was kind of like no
this is coming first this feels really
important and now i'm so grateful
we did we did because as we were writing
it it just makes so much sense that this
is obviously what we would be doing next
it's like
what we've learned from each other and
from our sessions together this is the
accumulation of like everything we've
been through filtered down into kind of
these little gold nuggets and we wrote
it because we love love like we just
love souls we just want people to
connect on that level we do couples work
and
and even with our kids or with our
friends it's like we want those deep
meaningful conversations you know
we we don't want to just kind of like
how are you doing on the surface i think
we
long to be with people and meet
on that soul level so this book was our
attempt at creating the map for that of
like really how do we get stuck or how
do we stop ourselves from that meeting
place on an ego level or just be in
trauma or attachment issues or
reactivity and then how do we really
just meet and i think from that first
paragraph and the title of our book what
we really wanted to
speak to is that universal piece
like we didn't want this to be the book
for
some you know special people that are
into doing relationship work we really
wanted this to speak to that common
longing that i think we all have and
it's this
and i wanted people to recognize that in
themselves
as they were reading the book
yeah like i wanted to ask the readers
can you recognize that part in yourself
that since the day you were born has
been longing to be met in unconditional
love and that doesn't mean just romantic
relationship but with with everyone in
in all interactions and uh that that
craving we have for authenticity
and and then examine really what is that
really why
why do we care why do we care if it's a
superficial interaction or an authentic
uh interaction
sure and
and what it comes down for
for lisa and i and what we've seen with
clients is because there's something
inherent within us that wants a soul the
soul connection
and and that that's where we actually
grow and transform
and where we actually
meet each other and have can have
spiritual experiences within our
lifetime and that's why we chose that
word holy we actually had a couple
different titles we tried like the
mystics guide to relationships or
the souls guide to relationship and then
we're like you know we really want to
use holy on purpose because it's usually
just associated with these ideas of
religion or spirituality but we're kind
of like what is love if not holy and i
think the reason people are disappointed
in relationships is because that's the
factor that's missing it's more did i
get what i thought i wanted is it on my
checklist of what i wrote as what i
wanted
or am i opening
am i humbling that ego part of myself
and allowing
the divine and allowing love as an
energy to be present in my relationships
and it's like any type of
prayer you have to kind of start with
the intention and create the altar and
for us the altar is even the idea that
that's a possibility and then the energy
of love can come in and actually has so
much grace and changes the game in the
relationship if you invite that element
in but if you view your relationships as
sacred i think it's really
hard to do relationship work unless you
first bring in that element of viewing
it as sacred because then you can do
much deeper work
i feel like this is a that that
realization is a later part of the
process like in my mind at least in my
experience there's childhood part
there's understanding so i think we'll
start there and then there's also sort
of the self part in trying to heal the
aspects of yourself to be able to
receive it right to just simply
receiving love is not always something
people know how to do and so
let's backtrack and i might just sort of
touch on chapters but it might not be in
order here but i think that we start
with like what is it that what is it
that shapes us
um
like what happens in our childhood what
is the what is the what is the
progression that puts us in this place
where we
i feel like it's almost like life is
about this process of like
you know having bad operating systems
like you know you've got like aol dial
up and then
you
like get older and you're like this is
just not working and you're like it
works but not well and then you finally
have to figure out how to upgrade the
systems and so there's kind of like an
unlearning that happens and a
re-learning um or even a letting go is a
very much a part of it so
back to childhood what is happening that
makes us like we are yeah
well that initial longing that i was
talking about that i
believe we're all born with and i think
it's this blueprint to search for love
and to search for
for what's real in life and so i think
we all have that inherent longing and i
think that longing is for a perfect love
but then we are searching for that
perfect love through imperfect people
and so and we're all imperfect you know
and we all have our our [ __ ] and our
wounds and sorry not not i don't know if
i'm allowed to swear on this
uh where all you like yeah great and
that's why we name the podcast holy and
human because we are very realistic
about the human part of that equation
and
yeah the wounds attachment issues yeah
so i think talk about that i don't think
that because i don't think that's
something people that always really know
about i don't think that's something
i mean even for me just realizing you
know in the last
six or eight years like
in the last three or four years how
pertinent and deep and
impactful
childhood programming and childhood
experiences are whether they're with
your family whether that's with some
crush that broke up with you and like
imprinted some
traumatic memory of something that where
you learn to judge yourself in some way
or put yourself down like there's so
much stuff that happens and you think as
you go through your life like it's you
it's you it's you and then finally you
go it's me every time every time every
time
yeah so you know i think that's some i
really would love you guys to speak to
that that that part of us that that part
of us that gets programmed what happens
what's going on
yeah well i think where we really
start the work with holy love is first
recognizing where we've been
disappointed in love
and where love has wounded us because i
think we need to face those things first
and be really crystal clear about what
that is uh because like i was saying
when we're searching for this perfect
love through imperfect people
it can be really a common experience to
start becoming
disenchanted with love and
uh and have wounds come up have negative
relationship experiences or have parents
that don't emotionally reflect us and
and things like that and so we be we can
become uh disenchanted and believe that
love itself is a compromise
that oh for me to be loved in
relationship for me to receive this
amazing gift of love i need to act a
certain way and you know i should be a
certain way i should be with this type
of person so we start ourselves putting
conditions on love
we're like oh well
my past relationships have gone like
this so i need to act this way and my
next relationship or i won't get any
love
and and like
just like consciously or unconsciously
is that happening yeah i i would say
sometimes both i definitely
unconsciously but i think
we really
start
it's almost like we have no other data
except for our own experience so you
look at your past which is usually
you know fraught with with issues and
then make predictions based on what's
happened
and
that's all coming from ego like it's
kind of like you can't solve a problem
from the energy level in which it was
created
right so it's like we're in beta state
and the ego and then we're trying to
make these predictions and assumptions
from
that place instead of understanding how
to actually connect to love as an energy
so that we raise the vibration and get
out of
all of those disappointments all of
those things that happened in childhood
we all have so much of that and it's
like they say
the first five years of your life are
the most important in your whole life in
terms of determining if the world is a
safe loving place if you're being seen
are you being
mirrored in that way and if you don't
get that
you really do have to consciously
do work
to fix
that time period in terms of your
nervous system in terms of being open to
love and i and it goes on
more than five i mean you know you've
seen us as parents we spend so we're so
aware i think we're almost sometimes too
aware of that our impact as parents on
our kids
lives and so we are very intense on
ourselves in terms of parents of how do
we do today did we mirror their soul
because we know we're setting up their
orientation for all their relationships
and we've prioritized that over anything
else like over our career over financial
choices like that has been our top
thing because i just feel like if you
bring kids in the world and you
fail at that
it's to me it's the most important thing
well i think also when when we work with
people in sessions that's what we see
all the time is people that if they
haven't been emotionally met uh when
they're young that that's where we start
the work and so we have a big section of
our book that's dedicated to inner child
work and i
absolutely love inner child work because
uh
as you know as we work how we work with
saul is we encourage people to
intuitively connect to their eternal
self to their soul self
this is the part of them that existed
before they were born and that exists
after they die and this is the part of
you that knows how to navigate love our
ego is not great at navigating love but
our soul
truly knows how to navigate love
and your soul is that source of
unconditional love
so every time we talk to our soul every
time we intuitively check in with our
soul we are in a way doing re-parenting
work because we're taking our lower self
our self that's pleasing conditional
love and connecting to our unconditional
self and bringing that love
energetically down into the body
and having a healing experience through
that and most of us and we're not
perfect parents by any means but i think
that's how we orient what our goals are
in terms of our day and parenting is how
much was just doing and how much was
being how much were we present
on a being level because that's what
really
that's what soul connection is and i
think what's amazing is how
much potential we have as humans if we
didn't get that golden ticket and our
parenting agreement that we can still
heal and
grow so much through our connection with
our soul and love and so it's kind of
like if you're listening and you didn't
have that amazing parenting and you're
hearing how impactful that is
that might be true and that might be why
some of your relationships have been
harder but it's not like a lost cause by
any means it's just kind of like now you
get
to do that re-parenting work and it's
actually
it sounds annoying like another thing i
have to do but it's actually so it feels
so good
yeah anytime you bring compassion and it
doesn't have to take forever you don't
need to spend years on that you know
sometimes you do i think uh
usually we don't heal in an instance you
know we kind of come back to an issue
and we keep uh working on it but uh soul
is as close as your next breath getting
that information from soul and getting
that information from what love would
say in a situation so often we see when
people really dial into their soul that
they get the intuitive information how
to move forward very quickly and i see
it like um when you're playing pool no
matter how bad it gets of if the other
person's winning the game's not over
till that next shot you always have an
opportunity
to change the game around no matter how
late in the game it is and i think i
mean i used to work in rehabs and jails
so i worked with people who had tons of
trauma and really not great situations
and coming in the world and i saw
miracles happen all the time of that
pool game just
i'm making a change like i'm turning it
around this late in the game after
murders or you know crazy things have
gone down and being like you know what
i'm gonna give this love thing a shot
and somebody's got to be able to break
the cycle right i mean otherwise the
cycle never ends for all of humanity and
that just isn't the case
um we've got you know every so often
someone comes along who looks at these
things looks at these patterns and and
heals them for the
ancestrally through through generations
um
you studied um carl young um psychology
young young how do you say it young yeah
it's a weird word union
jungian psychology
um
and
do they teach attachment styles and oh
yeah i mean it's a huge part and i think
that's so
amazing can you touch on that because i
think this is something where for me as
a learner
um
understanding attachment styles and
being able to go oh that's me it kind of
like all of a sudden puts you into this
other this bucket and then all of a
sudden within that bucket there's all
kinds of other little things and you can
kind of like distill things down to
for me this is how it was where i was
like oh for me i am anxious attachment
right i'm afraid of being abandoned i'm
never good enough
and so when i knew that then i was
because of having someone explain what
an
anxious attachment is and and all of the
attachment styles i could identify and
it really helps with the process so
maybe if it's can you uh you know
highlight the the styles and and explain
what the what the tendencies are yeah i
mean this is a topic i'm really
passionate about yeah we're very into
the structure that hurts lisa but uh i
was like let me encourage i love this
question yeah
me too
generally there's three different
attachment styles uh there's more uh
specific categories within those but the
broadest categories are avoid an
attachment anxious attachment and secure
attachment
and
avoid an attachment is
when we feel um emotionally threatened
in a relationship or we feel insecure
that our impulse is to distance our
impulse is to keep somebody at an arm's
length
and this can show up in a lot of
different ways it can show up in
literally this feeling of uh you know we
got in a fight oh now i'm going to go
out with my friends you know i'm just
going to like
vacate this argument and i'm just going
to leave
but it can also show up uh in
techniques like sometimes grand romantic
gestures
actually are a way of not being
authentically intimate by consuming time
with
uh grand acts of romance opposed to
having a real emotional authentic
vulnerability instead of just being like
here i am let's meet on this level it's
like performing sure am i enough right
here just like this something simple you
know
yeah that's the and it comes from that
same place of am i lovable
well i don't know if i am so i'm gonna
do these big things to kind of
look over here yeah
and then anxious attachment style is
this um
when there's conflict of this i want to
bring you closer
and i'm going to try to pull you as
close as i can
and
but with it with anxiety on it because
there's fear of if i don't have you at a
certain uh level of intimacy perhaps
this is not gonna last and so it is uh
fear-based
and
and more clinging and that's what i that
was what i had to work through adam was
more avoidant yeah um and what i like to
say about the attachment styles too is
that uh
10 i think i think it's like 15 of the
population has secure attachments so
this is not like an uncommon thing
in our society uh i think most people
are screwed up yeah
absolutely we should comfort everyone
yeah we're all messy even the boat
yeah so it's really really common so
don't feel bad if you identify with one
of these categories uh you know i had my
own avoiding attachment stuff to work
through at least i had her anxious
attachment stuff to work through and
like we said we're not supposed to be
perfect when we come to relationship in
fact sometimes it's i've seen it can be
a more miraculous healing journey when
you come to a relationship with all your
baggage because then if you really heal
that with a person
then you build such a deep level of
trust with that person yeah we have been
through it like especially in the
beginning of our relationship and
normally um those two styles attract
each other where you'll have somebody's
avoidance and someone who's anxious and
then you just have
the anxious person you know wrestling
them down pulling them in questioning
them getting more neurotic getting
analytical and then the avoidant
person's going away and then withdrawing
and coming back and it becomes this kind
of can't live with you can't live
without you sometimes passionate kind of
like
projective ex can be explosive
relationship and um
they activate each other right they like
feed into each other those two styles
and if it's unconscious it's a really
bad situation if it's conscious it's an
opportunity it's like oh look this is
actually kind of awesome because it's so
at the surface all those feelings that
there's a lot of potential for healing
but it takes
a certain type of the reason our first
we go on in the book about a healthy ego
is because we don't speak of ego more
yogically of annihilate the ego get rid
of the ego we're coming more
psychologically to that idea of you need
a healthy ego an ego can be good or bad
depending if it's conscious or
unconscious but a healthy ego is capable
of staying when it's uncomfortable so
you need someone and that's the human
part of holy and human of like assessing
in your relationship is this person
capable
of handling that emotional dissonance
when those old wounds surface and then
sitting through it because if they can
sit through it takes courage and it
takes persistence
and it takes being conscious of what's
happening if you're not conscious then
it's just like this relationship sucks
i'm not just you're not what i want i'm
not getting what i need from you because
they're uncomfortable but if it's
conscious around
actually i really want you
and because of that desire i'm annoyed
because i'm feeling all my old family
stuff and my body and i so i feel
terrified and i if they can it's like
one can you identify
those feelings which is
not always that sounds simple people
think like identifying feelings like
yeah of course you know how you feel but
honestly most people have no idea how
they feel when i used to work in rehabs
that was so shocking to me we had a
feeling chart similar to the one like we
put in this book
we'd pass it around and be like pick
three feelings that you're feeling right
now off this chart and and you'd think
that'd be so basic and me who had been
through
pacific or graduate institute jungian
training like you'd think i would be
able to do that pretty well and i
remember getting handed the feeling
chart and being like
well like how
because the idea of how we think we're
feeling is usually different than what's
actually happening in our body in the
moment so it's coming into the present
moment
which takes kind of trauma
withdrawing deprogramming to do that
and then identifying what am i and
usually it can be mixed you can be like
excited and nervous or you know inspired
and terrified so it's starting to
identify
those places and then bringing love and
healing to the places that need
attention
within that
so
in a relationship there's so much going
on i see like we're like these universes
and we can't collide together and then
you have like a third universe that's
created by these two universes
and it's like what's that universe about
in terms of the soul lessons and
contracts and what is going on and also
this might be out there for some people
but we believe it's like a soul journey
so it's also not just this lifetime here
it's broadening right to like
and whether you believe that or not it's
just
there's a lot going on
and so so it's kind of like getting
aware of
like well what one thing i was gonna say
was uh one of the reasons we
chose the title holy love was because we
wanted to move away from this idea that
love is simply uh just an emotion
and that love is actually a process
so
one way i think people see relationships
is like love is something that you are
going to go get in a relationship
and so you
crave a relationship because you want
that feeling and then when you have your
first conflict are disappointed about
something with your partner then you're
like well i didn't get that feeling so
i'm out i guess that's not love
or i'm doing something wrong or i'm
unlovable but if we see love as a
process that's happening to us because
we see love as a moment-to-moment thing
the way that love is showing up right
now in this moment for us for this
conversation is different than it's
gonna show up 30 minutes later so you
have to stay tuned to what love is you
can't predict you can't put any rules on
how love should act
you have to be open to it receiving the
intuitive
information uh from love so in that way
we really see love as a spiritual
journey yeah that makes me think of a
statement that i've heard recently that
i thought and i think it was jordan
peterson who said it that um
relationships you could even maybe even
put the word love instead of it right um
is a decision not a discovery
and that there's i think there's some
truth there and that you know
you know you you
you have this
situation with a person and and the
relationship is a decision you're like
okay yeah like i'm all in it's not just
sort of like let's just see how you act
tomorrow it's like no
and so the hard part is is like how do
we find ourselves in sync with the right
person so that we don't make a bad
decision i think we would also say i
mean i like that what you're saying and
i totally agree with that and i would
say
for us
it's kind of semantics but for us i
think love is both of those things it's
a dece you make the decision
so that then you're discovering
like a whole other
realm
yeah of love that's a potential once
you're consistent and made that real
committed decision
because i'm discovering stuff every
moment with adam right but it's not it's
not like
discovering if i want to be here right
it's more it's more um
through our
trust and through those decisions we
made when it was hard when we wanted to
leave and we had arguments in the
beginning when we were working on our
attachment stuff that like adam would i
remember once he said to me like
i want it because he used to fish and go
up to alaska and you know do this like
manly thing off by himself and i
remember when he was like i think i want
to go to alaska and just like get out of
here but like i can't even leave you
because i know if i'm like alone in a
fishing boat in alaska like you're still
gonna be there with me like it was like
he was realizing that there was no
getting away
from the love i would say that's
actually the moment i
i healed my avoiding attachment or a
piece of it was we had gotten an
argument and i had that emotional
impulse to run right i was like i want
out like and it wasn't because of
anything specific it was because my
trauma was up you know my my inner child
wounds from when i was little
and so that was activated but then this
feeling of elisa had touched something
true in me
and i knew that
if i ran if i had left her
that i would almost be haunted by
her experience because it would be like
oh there was this thing that was true
that i missed out on and so i realized
in that moment that there was no escape
in a way it was the wisdom of no escape
of one and i think you know we all talk
about how we want love we're all like we
want love we want the perfect
relationship but what most people don't
realize is that love reveals all of our
wounds love brings up all the places we
feel like we're not loved and where we
have self beliefs that we're not loved
so it's really hard but to get to your
question about how do you know it's that
person right how do you know that this
is somebody that's worth investing in
and worth uh building that trust to go
through all the wounds with
we have a huge section of our book
dedicated to trying to recognize who is
a soul match for you
and
so that is taking a lot you know
all our dating websites focus on
egoic traits for making matches for
people they're like oh what are your
hobbies what's your personality type
what you know what's your religion
there's what do you think you want
so there's based off of all of uh egoic
traits and characteristics and and not
to dismiss those because those are
important too but what we lack i think
as a culture is being able to
inherently
sense
somebody's essence
of who they are on an energetic level so
not who they are based on their actions
or their words
uh but who they are as a soul
so we really see one uh metaphor we use
in the book is it's like complementary
colors like you can be with somebody and
your color feels less vibrant and it
kind of loses its hue
but if you're with a soul that matches
you usually have a feeling of more life
force of more energy
and so we we bring it to a somatic level
of really trying to deprogram your
beliefs of what you think a relationship
should be and see if you can get into a
uh emotionally aware
place of becoming aware of that
biofeedback from another person somatic
just means how it feels in your body how
does that feel and um we have a whole
chapter on tough love because it's not
sometimes loving the loving information
is to leave
because sometimes
and and i think that's really hard
sometimes for people because the idea of
being spiritual or compassionate is kind
of like sometimes people interpret that
as i'll enable anything i'll stay even
positive
yeah and i'll just like not necessarily
see
what's happening but if something's
really toxic or really unhealthy then
you have to kind of listen to love about
not enabling or or potentially leaving
but i think we're so realistic about
where the human is capable because even
if you have some wonderful soul
connection if in that lifetime that
person is
because of their nature of their trauma
and if they're also just not going to
care about healing basically right like
if they have the trauma and they don't
want to do the work
you can only get so far yeah it is a we
have this personal accountability of
like
are we going to choose because it's hard
sometimes to stay and open to love
when your stuff's triggered so it's kind
of like
also being realistic with like is this
person capable of hanging
when the stuff gets tough or are they
going to project out and be like well
maybe it's just you
yeah because they could only go so far
then in that case yeah you can only go
as far as your healing essentially and
you know
if you can't make peace with yourself
it's hard to make peace with the other
person so that actually kind of brings
me back i wasn't sure if we were gonna
get back to this question but i think
this is an opportunity is your the three
attachment styles really the two in
particular that are the most prevalent
um secure you're all good you guys
aren't even listening um
why would i read a book about
relationships
you're good
you know 2.5 kids and you know
well one shout out to the secure
attachment people yeah shout out
yeah is uh we love you
we respect thanks for being there no a
secure attachment actually you know in
movies we're really shown often kind of
that combustive part of relationships
and we see that as romantic sometimes
often we see that the passion an
avoidant chaser runner dynamic as like a
true dynamic uh
and often secure attachment people can
actually struggle to get
relationships or dates because people
see
it's boring appealing as boring because
there's not that emotional
yeah tug so
then this brings me to the question
which is can you
explain to people
what it is that creates that attachment
style of anxious or avoidant what is the
pattern of the parent um
that uh that establishes that sort of
relationship there's so many things like
because it can be you having a parent
that's an addict and so maybe they're
there but not there or maybe there's a
history of like abuse in the home so any
type of abuse um definitely addiction
and then there's also things like that
covert narcissism right where it's like
these are the people where they're on
the pta they're showing up at all the
games they are bringing cookies to
whatever um but there might be this
coldness this manipulation and control
in the relationship so then the kids not
really receiving true soul reflection or
love it's more if you do xyz you get our
love so it's conditional love
and so then they learn to be little good
soldiers
of getting mommy and daddy's approval
which might even look very socially
acceptable and enviable to many people
but what's really going on then is
you're creating a self-esteem issue in
the kids where they're like i'm not
lovable and um
and then
unless i perform or
unless i whatever and so
then they sacrifice getting to know who
they truly are authentically and as a
soul because they're so busy working so
hard to perform and they've learned to
identify as that idea of who they are
from programming so that's called
persona we talk about that in the book
so so persona is like a word for mask
so you start to think you are the mask
and and it makes these kind of
chameleon-like people who don't have
this solid
consistent kind of
attachment style and knowing and um you
know i think my parents are pretty great
in many ways and then i went to grad
school and learned about
like all these issues and then you see
you start to see um even though people
are doing their best and that's usually
what it is most parents are just trying
their best with what they were raised
with right
um
and then you start to see like oh my
gosh i didn't get all these other things
and i have some work to do um but also
kind of understanding not being too
perfectionistic on that like yeah we all
have work to do but also like be
compassionate to where you are do your
best like um because it's all
it's all in process right like none of
it's like this perfect situation but
they generally say that avoid an
attachment people that that wound is
initiated when you get pretty much no
emotional reflection
or that nurturing contact so if you're
uh i think the best example is like if
you're a kid and you get hurt if you
skin your knee was your parent that type
of parent of like just get up get over
it you know you're you're okay so that's
there's i think there's a lot of
complexity in where avoid an attachment
comes from but that's the general sort
of
how they group that into a category and
then anxious attachment is often when we
get mixed messages like a bit of both
where sometimes
uh we get that from our parents and
sometimes we don't and so we never know
what to expect and so we grow up where
we feel an uncertainty where we're like
i don't know if this is secure
i'm testing the water uh but you know
i'm not sure so there's this hesitancy
and this kind of and then there can be
more of an emphasis on like oh maybe if
i perform in a certain way i'll get that
maybe if you know so you never know so
it creates anxiety so that's why it's
anxious attachment the other two things
i mean there's so many things that cause
these issues but
i said addiction
you know
trauma from like
violence and things like that but also
mental health issues if your parent
is really swinging in bipolar states
that can be tough on kids or if um some
mental health issues also
personality types like
sometimes i'm a kid who
is an enfj on the myers-briggs which
means i'm wired to be
all about big abstract concepts of
philosophy and then always on a feeling
state i make my decisions based on how
i'm feeling and i had two parents that
were thinkers and made decisions through
thinking and then also a little more
they were s's so a little more um just
here and now in the world of like what
makes sense instead of just like
abstract concepts of value
and so
that created a particular type of trauma
in me in the sense of like interpreting
who i am naturally is not being
right in a particular way like not being
um fit for society like just a certain
kind of way ugly yeah where you're like
something's wrong with me i'm not like
functioning in the same way
nothing was wrong with me the whole time
nothing was wrong with them the whole
time but we didn't have
uh
there was a part of me that started to
get anxious growing up because i it was
never communicated to me that my nature
was purposeful or how or why they
couldn't role model that to me because
that wasn't their experience or
orientation so i think what it really
all boils down to is if
you are seen
on a soul level and i and so that's
really what holy love is all about is
seeing each other on a soul level and so
that's that type of emotional reflection
i think we're talking about and it's
like i'm so grateful for my parents in
so many other ways and the reason i'm
saying this is because i just want
people to not think it's so black and
white it's like
it's it's it's like you don't have to
like pull away from everything that's
been semi good either you just need to
kind of recognize the places where you
weren't seen or being together in that
energy and then start to really rewire
that programming
yeah i agree i think that's important to
say because they're
you know it's talking about this even
with my parents you know like at first
when you start to say trauma i mean you
know stay abandoned and all these words
like they're you know my dad like worked
his ass off so that he could provide but
he was gone all week and only home on
the weekends and so like my little you
know couple year old self feels doesn't
know that doesn't have the ability to to
to digest the dynamic and so i just feel
like there's an inconsistency with with
with it
it's all love when it's there but then
when it's not there i'm like what's
happened did i do something wrong so
then of course when i started racing and
you know
um you know that was like i'd do
anything to keep him around because my
my fear was that he'd leave again and so
i would put up with everything which
sort of made me feel like i wasn't good
enough because there was always more to
do and so i love that you shared that
because that is usually what it is for
people it's like the person the parents
showing up like i'm doing my best i
don't understand and but it's not always
received that way and that's just
because of you were whatever six seven
eight so we're in different
developmental states so we're
interpreting we don't know we're not
like adults yet um
i had an ex-boyfriend who was a
professional golfer and he was really
great when he was 18 he was like best in
the nation beat tiger woods one reason
he was so good was because his mom died
when he was young and no one talked
about it in the family and so he learned
to control
his rage and all his emotions through
golfing and so every day he was out
there practicing all day long i can get
this ball from point a to point b
without feeling a thing i'm very
controlled in my emotional state
and then later when he was like late
twenties went to therapy
starts talking about all the wounds from
his mother
his golf game went way down
but it was a sole
you know
like
success because now we're starting to
integrate but on the surface it looks
like wow digging into this stuff really
is sucking for my life
and not doing me any favors you know
well your new life's always going to
cost your old one you know exactly and
the idea is that it's going to be a
better one because the reason why you've
stepped into something that you feel
like you need to address so for people
listening they're like i feel like you
know like this maybe i have this pattern
or this isn't working from usually it's
like this isn't working for me right
like relationships don't work or jobs
just don't work for me or whatever you
know friendships break down or if
there's some kind of thing that's
happening that is another word for it as
a pattern and they're like i need to do
something about it and the thing is is
that you know once you face that it's
because the discomfort has become so
great i was actually just saying on the
phone this morning i was talking to my
sister and
um
you know we were talking about a a
friend's dynamic and it's like either
you know they will
either either the actually it was her
sorry it was hers and i was talking
about her job
and i said look i said you're doing your
best i said it'll either become obvious
the path forward and whatever you're
doing moving forward which is usually
not the case but it could happen like
that or the discomfort within becomes so
great that you can't stay any longer and
so i said that's usually the way it goes
that's usually how you make a transition
or change is that the discomfort becomes
so great so whether it's the people or
the
the routine that you have to be in or
the places you have to go or the people
you have to deal with
the things become so uncomfortable you
just have to get out and so yes it's
going to cost your your life your your a
lot of you know there might be friends
jobs things like that relationships that
fall away where you live who knows
something or many things can fall away
but it's all in the pursuit of getting
closer to who you really are and
dropping this what was the other word
for mask the persona persona yes to to
sort of dissolve the persona that you
created when you were young to make sure
that you were safe and fed and had
somewhere to sleep because like your
parents were everything and so i also
like this help my sister like you're i
mean i feel like a kind of a dick for
saying these things because i don't have
kids but
that every parent will give their kids
something and it's really like not about
not giving them some kind of thing to
deal with or maybe you're part of the 15
that's secure oh yeah they're out there
but um the unicorns um
but it's really and so this is where
it's going to come to my question
it's really about how you teach your
kids how to deal with things
and so how do you as parents
re-parent essentially and how do you how
are you writing the book on parenting
for yourselves so that you can you can
you can grow the next generation to have
the tools
yeah and kids are sponges so they it
doesn't matter what you tell them to do
like do this thing this is how it works
emotionally they're gonna do what you
did you know
so so
at the end of the day it's modeling you
know and and it will and that's what we
love about kids is in terms of spiritual
kind of like witnesses or you know
assignments they hold you accountable
they're like we got your number whatever
you're doing we're gonna reflect that
back like immediately so i mean we just
first we use a lot of language as things
are happening like if i'm stressed and i
know i'm acting kind of ridiculous i'll
be like
mom is stressed right now i'm acting a
little weird this might feel weird to
you i know this isn't my best state but
i'm gonna do this for a little bit and
hopefully my mood will change in 35
minutes you just might want to stay away
from me for a little bit like so what
i'm communicating is like your
intuition's correct
this isn't about you
and i'm accountable i'm identifying my
feelings i'm going in a process of going
to try to work through that the best i
can i think a lot of parents put a
pressure on themselves too to not ever
have arguments or to show their real
life stressors to their kids they try to
keep protect them from fertilized
and that i don't think that's helpful
for children i think that children need
to know that humans are messy that we're
not perfect that sometimes we're
stressed and sometimes we accidentally
shout across the room when we're in a
bad state or uh or get in a conflict
with our partners
and what they need to know is that that
is normal
and that you can work through it and
then here's some tools on how to and
that it's okay to communicate about we
have two kids that feel very comfortable
telling us because of how we've modeled
and told them like our younger one is
like oh my gosh she's so
clear about all this stuff that he'll
just tell us like when you and papa were
arguing about that thing i felt weird in
my stomach and i didn't like it and i
didn't know what was gonna happen i'll
be like i'm sorry you felt that why
here's what was going on for us i'll try
to use developmentally appropriate
language because you don't want to
parentify your kids and make them feel
like
it's their job to fix the adults
problems but you also don't want to deny
their happening and you want to just
because that's what i you know some
people think the healthiest thing is not
arguing but um
if you know the work of john gottman he
can
predict divorce up to like 98 or
whatever and it's really it's not about
not arguing it's about how you argue and
a lot of it's about communication so
it's kind of like identifying things and
talking about it and um and then just
not arguing in toxic ways like passive
aggressive or stonewalling or the silent
treatment you know
i'm being able to recognize like when
you're in the grip of stress that's not
a time to communicate to your children
that's the time you go off by yourself
you need a bathroom break and to go
breathe or whatever you need to do also
i think the greatest compliment we can
give our kids is spending time with them
and so i think that often we think oh we
get anxious as parents i get anxious all
the time you know like i have my focus
being like oh my my kid's success in the
world like i need to prepare them as
best i can i need to give them every
single tool so that they can have a
fulfilling life but it can become
it can come from an anxious place
and so and i think if our kids feel that
if they feel like we're they're always a
uh improvement project and we're trying
to make them better and better
that then they they they believe that
themselves they say oh to be successful
in life i need to put this pressure on
myself they internalize the pressure
and so i think one of the greatest
things we can do with our kids is just
spend relax have fun with them have fun
with them we try to we actively seek out
comedy to watch with our family we watch
afv we actually for my birthday we're
doing this stand-up comedy night with
our friends so everybody including the
kids would have a minute or two that
have to come out and do something funny
and the reason why we push that is
because humor heals and humor if you
have that where you can make fun of
stuff while it's happening it's so
healthy in
psychology school and therapy school we
learned about the good enough parent so
it's not about being perfect they call
it the good enough and what defines a
good enough parent is this these kind of
flexible traits of like we can talk
about things we can communicate we're
doing our best but we're open we're
transparent we're taking accountability
if if a kid comes through and says you
failed me in this way you're like i hear
you you're not denying or minimizing or
running you're in
contact and you're emotionally
connecting and that's what creates
healthy attachment is kind of like
it's not always perfect but i know i'm
safe knowing
they can handle a conversation about it
without withdrawing and then we start to
do that internally so that when life is
stressed we don't like something at our
job we've had that modeling so we're
like
i didn't like what my boss did but i
have the courage to maybe communicate it
in a in an appropriate way
because i've had that modeling so if we
don't get the modeling then we just need
to kind of like
learn how and i think in that example of
a boss i think the the real tool we're
trying to give them is not giving their
self-worth away to somebody externally
so not believing if my boss is
disappointed in me that means i'm a
disappointing person and so that's it's
being able to hold that nuance and that
complexity of oh my boss can be
disappointed in me and it has nothing to
do with who i am i think that's such
important information and i think such
good
advice as well but what comes to mind is
how
you know when you're dealing with a kid
you can pretty much tell them whatever
you want like if you wanted to tell them
like no i'm fine everything is fine no
there's no problem or like
you know whatever the dynamic is the
parent can look like the good guy to the
kid and um make and keep the peace
egoically with themselves that
everything is fine
and it feels like basically like kids
get gaslit a lot probably
and you know which is just denying your
reality the way that you see and feel it
um and and someone telling you it's not
that way it's some other way and i mean
that's a i think that really brings
disconnect with our our soul
and our true self because like you said
so so important that you said this is
that
you learn how to trust your your
intuition you learn how to trust your
body
and kids i mean i i mean if i didn't
know all this information i have kid and
i'd probably try and look like the good
guy a lot of times and try and you know
i would probably try and you know
even if i thought it helped them
um but the truth is is that the more you
deny their intuition and they hit it on
the head the less connected they are to
it because their survival relies on them
not thinking that way anymore
yeah that's perfectly spoken and that's
what happens kids will be like oh
everything's fine but then they have a
stomach ache or then they're not
sleeping well and any therapist knows
what happens is then the kid is usually
in this family system oh the issues with
the kid the kid's not getting good
grades the kids having these things
happen they're having nightmares why are
they wetting the bed at 12 years old or
whatever and then they bring you the kid
to therapy and then it's like fix that
problem fix the stomach aches fix
whatever
but then you start to see through
talking to the kid or witnessing family
dynamics
oh they're just
showing
the
they're revealing how the system's not
working yeah exactly
and if the other part of the system
isn't willing to do the work
yeah then then you have to kind of just
protect and support the kid as best you
can i mean i used to work in juvenile
hall and it's like there was so much of
that happening right where it's like the
kid's the problem
and the kid is traumatized the kid is
wounded and then we're doing things in
our system to
re-traumatize the kid like putting a
16-year-old in isolation
like wild things so yeah um that gas lit
piece that you mentioned i think is so
important in all relationships yeah we
were asked
i guess i'll visit that later but
that like you said it can create an
eternal distrust in our own emotions
we may be feeling all these emotions as
a kid and just think they're wrong you
know or think they're misplaced or i
think it's our problem think we have an
anxiety disorder or a self-confidence
issue or something like that but really
what it is is we don't feel safe in our
bodies and we're we're denying that in
ourselves so a lot of soul work is
reacquainting yourselves with with your
truth
what is really true for you
and
and then using that truth to navigate
life that's really all of the work if we
were going to say it in one sentence it
would be
find your own truth
and then
how do you make decisions from that
truth
and trust trust your gut i mean i just
heard a story someone sent me an email
about they went to a spiritual retreat
where you think you're going to be doing
this work and they're getting gaslit by
the people running it of basically they
had an issue with the thing they
communicated to them they didn't want to
take accountability and so they're like
you're just jealous you're just you have
an issue this is your attachment wound
you need to work on that person's
vulnerable and kind of traumatized so
they're like maybe that's right this is
the the expert telling me this i must
have some issue i need to work on so
that's why we
so
promote connecting to your soul and not
giving your power to anyone
to really developing a true spiritual
teacher or healer or therapist is going
to be someone who's truly encouraging
for real that relationship with your own
empowerment
instead of i want to feel special as a
therapist give me your power and i'm the
expert and let me tell you like
so and the way you know that is you just
trust you can feel it like do i really
feel safe with this person or do i feel
like with this healer i'm needing to
perform and then sometimes it's like a
a trauma what do you call it when you
have an addiction to the trauma where
you're kind of like
so it's kind of like in some ways people
sometimes seek that out like literally
will go
to
those people in relationship or as
healers that will gaslight them because
that's what they know that's what
they've been used to yeah i think the
question you can ask yourself in that
situation is if whether it's a spiritual
teacher or a therapist or a friend or a
parent is does this person either want
me i think in the case of a spiritual
teacher to be more like them
and do they want me to become more of
some like enlightened persona or more of
myself
and i think uh within the family system
the question can be more like does this
person want me to play a role or do they
want me to be more of myself
that's important to say um because it's
like i always find prompts being a
really good um
sort of way to open the door to a space
an energetic space
or perspective because we're so
desensitized to our patterning and are
the way that we uh
orient and associate and choose to be
around people why we do and it's like
the questions are so helpful
um to be able to get into
it's like it's like almost like it's
sort of like goes around the ego and
then you have to kind of kind of get
down to it to the true self to the to
the soul to be able to ask those
questions i love that you said that by
the way because in this book we worked
so hard on our prompts because we know
the wording makes a big difference of
that entry point of like how your
because just even a different word
change can like should and it can make a
big difference and we got an email
yesterday from somebody who had read
love meet your soul my first book and
they're like thank you for putting so
many prompts
because um i had a feeling an intuition
like that my questions to my soul just
weren't tweaked because of my
programming in the right way and then
having those prompts so it's when you
say that because yeah i think prompts
are major major really helpful and for
those who really want to do the work i
mean of course then it's the next step
to like answer that question and you'd
be surprised how quickly you can get
into the space and there's um an inertia
that happens really quick where you
really want to start figuring it out and
there are answers and that's your soul
and that's that's been my experience
anyway and probably a lot of your
experience with working with people and
working with your own souls is that the
information is readily available like
you said adam it's your next breath like
you're you know that connection is just
right there and it's just
asking for cultivation and activation
and to answer your questions it's
usually such a no-da feeling of like
when i connect with myself she's like
hello i've been here i don't know what
you've been doing but i'm so right here
for you like you didn't have to work
that hard
it is and it's usually like there's a
there's a peaceful feeling there's an
unders it's like it lands softly instead
of
being harsh it's kind of it's a soft
truth even when even though there's
sometimes hard truths is like it lands
softer and you're just like yeah because
it's with love right that's how you know
you're talking your soul is it coming
from that energy
of love and it's just it is an energy
it's a certain feeling and it
brings something for those who haven't
done it i mean honestly it's just start
to ask yourself questions it can even
just like be simply stated as like
self-talk just like or free journaling
or free talking you know maybe it's good
to start off with you know your inner
child maybe how old is usually we can
identify with our inner child maybe as
an age right like maybe kind of like or
even pick an age um and then you just
start to say like hey you know how you
doing like say it say how are you doing
like just start with that and it's
amazing how it works but um earlier adam
you had mentioned um about being maybe
you said it at least i can't remember
which one of you but about healing
within relationships it's like we
are
essentially wounded within relationships
so it's imaginable that there will be
some sort of
ultimately like a final healing within
relationships because as you said it
develop you you enter you really deepen
that trust and and there's sort of like
it almost feels like it i'm very visual
so it's like almost feels like there's
there's more of a ceiling of the
of the of the wound when it is
integrated with someone there's a lot of
work you can do on your own for sure um
but within relationships there's even
more and it also is your is a wonderful
mirroring experiment in being a human
where you see yourself in the other
person
through triggers and all the other
dynamics um
and also through the good things you see
in them it's like you know if you if you
look at if one of you looks at the other
and is like see something really
beautiful that's that's within you
that's an aspect of you you really are
seeing yourself through that person and
so i want to ask like the final question
as to
you know what does holy love look like
and um you know how
how will we know how will we know when
we're in that
i love that i mean
we are relational beings so we're always
in relationship and when you said
earlier you know talk to that inner
child part that's very jungian because
the idea of jung's work is like we have
all these little sub characters within
us and we think we're just like i'm me
i'm a lisa am i just this one person but
the reality is depending on what happens
or what's triggered in me i might
suddenly be six year old alisa or i
might be wise at least you know based on
what's fluctuating so i think we're
changing kind of all the time through
all these little sub parts and so
holy love is anytime you're opening to
the true energy of love and that i mean
some of the most beautiful versions of
holy love i've seen are like nuns and
monks who are in deep relationship with
their higher self they're in an active
engaged relationship they're working
their inner child they're getting
reflected because it's a relationship so
you're hearing from your higher self so
if you're single you can also be in deep
relationship and that's why we call it
the four spiritual relationships because
it's like that inner relationship
between you
and your soul that's a real relationship
that might have projections or might
have intimacy issues so you can also
like and also nurtures you when i call
in sofia my soul
she's loving me in a way that sometimes
is intense to my ego so it's really like
relating right it's like
lisa has to receive has to learn to
receive to that level of love and i
think we're always like
i want love i want love i want love but
when the energy of love comes in it's
really
it makes you so vulnerable and it makes
you
reorient who you think you are so it is
such a
transformative but also intense process
and so um any building that relationship
anywhere is really useful but in a
relationship with another human well
what i was going to say first for the
listeners when elisa said sophia if you
don't know what she's talking about we
have a lot of exercises where we give
our soul a name so that we can create
that dialogue between
adam and my soul and that name becomes a
symbol of unconditional love
so
you know when you were talking earlier
and you're talking about connecting to
soul and you did that little like moment
of
where when you recognize it as truth
there's this feeling when we talk to
soul of recognition
and it's it's kind of this feeling
of oh i thought love was there i thought
love was there i expected love to be
here but now that i'm really hearing my
soul i'm like oh it's right here
and and there's a body recognition so
most of the time when we work on
sessions with people when they get their
soul information it's not some far out
abstract concept they've never heard of
before usually the information coming
through usually it's something like yeah
it is time to leave this relationship
and you actually already knew that you
know or it's
or you are avoiding an issue here and
you already knew that so there's a part
of us that already know you're going to
work overtime because you're just
terrified of feeling your stomach
feelings the feelings in your stomach
and i think the same is with holy love
so holy love our definition is is just
any moment you are experiencing
unconditional love so that can be
with somebody we've been married with
for 25 years or can be the barista at
the cafe for five minutes
and so are we able to access a state of
unconditional love with this other
person and i really stress the
definition of unconditional because
i think it's actually quite rare that we
really
allow ourselves to receive unconditional
love and be in a moment of unconditional
love i think we may feel unconditionally
loved by people in our lives
but can we together sit in a moment of
unconditional intimacy
where we're really connecting on that
level
and i would say that the first layers
what first comes up is like you said all
the wounds all the places we felt like
we weren't loved that's usually what's
blocking us from having that moment
and then when we release those emotions
or become aware of those emotions
start having a conversation with those
emotions
then it deepens
and so then we get to a place with that
person where we're like
something real is happening here and
you're touching a place in me that
hasn't been
recognized for a while
but then after we start peeling back
these layers and where elisa and my work
really takes a radical different
direction than most couples work
is we start to recognize the divine
nature within each other
so we really believe when you start
connecting to a soul and another person
and you're really connecting to that
eternal part of them
you start to open up to all the
mysteries of the universe you really
start to get more intuitive information
about everything in your life because
you get more
in touch with
ultimate reality
and i think even it's so hard down here
as humans there's so much stuff we're
always dealing with but holy love is an
assumption of love in the universe an
assumption that's what's behind
everything even the horrific things on
this planet is
like adam said in the beginning of the
book because he wrote that beginning was
it's this is class this is love 101
university so
your your story with your dad earlier
it's like because i had a similar story
with my dad in a different way but it's
like so that was hard when you were
younger maybe of like you're gone and
i'm going to perform but also on a soul
level so it's the soul contracts is you
chose that experience with him
earlier for for the perfect yeah like
set up of what that was going to force
you to learn consciously so that you
could really embody that and bring that
energy to the accumulation of your soul
energy
so now you know love because you've
lived through that
and experienced that and he was your
partner in that process so then you
start to have
even though that was tough and even
though that didn't feel good i reckon i
honor you on a soul level for what the
dance we were doing in this lifetime how
we played these roles for each other me
as daughter you as father but because
those are also roles of like
love
like reclaiming love embodying love
where i was scared for him maybe of love
and then just coming into that you know
um so
and i'm definitely not trying to put
words into your experience or or your
thing
you know or your dads but i think it's a
perfect example
of like what it all because we can get
and we do and we should grieve the
experience of our younger self but
all our work is an assumption of how
wise your soul was
to kind of know through that experience
there was going to be some kind of
particular learning unique to you and i
think especially in your situation where
you're unique because of what you've
done and what you've lived so
just the uniqueness of that was how your
soul was like you know how we're going
to learn this
we're going to learn it through this
really interesting and public experience
so that she knows it so well because
that's that's kind of um we have one
exercise called mystic mad libs which i
love which is kind of like
if you think of something hard in your
life and you assume you have to pretend
maybe if it was done from love
what was i really becoming the expert
master teacher of through that weird
unique experience
and and when we when we identify that
then we start to feel less like
victimized by everything and more of
like
oh i understand what i was learning
there yeah you can also hold the
experience in more love you know so i
think it's not saying oh well there was
a lesson here and so i wasn't you know
don't deserve to feel my human emotions
with it i think you can also connect to
yeah more love on that through that
vantage point
yeah and to be yeah and to be uh if
maybe there's someone that's con
slightly confused it's saying you're
saying that um and maybe well
i'm gonna reflect what i'm hearing you
say which is
that we come in with agreements and soul
contracts with people and we choose our
situation and you know i came in with
this understanding and so did my dad
like hey you know this is what i'm gonna
go do and he's like i'll be that guy
don't i'll do it i'll do it like i know
where you're going and i got you and you
know he's like i'll be willing to
sacrifice this sort of you know the time
with you or whatever it is that created
the dynamic so that you can
be thrust deeper into this
reality that is going to help more
people be be more be more important
overall
and and also just show you yourself and
help me on a soul level develop these
certain aspects and areas because as we
said at the very beginning that
you know
this is a continuum and it's not that
this one life is the be-all end-all and
and everybody has their opinion on that
but i do find it's almost like a little
bit of a form of religion in a way it's
like this this rings true to me and
feels right but it's also
there's a sense of peace in that to know
that like you've come into this life and
you know you chose your challenges and
you've got sort of a soul evolution to
work on and that just like the light
spectrum is this big and we see right
here we're just right here right now and
we've come from here and we're going
here it's a big big spectrum
and um and i think about that and i
really think about oh sweet dolores
cannon do you guys know yeah of course
love dolores she's passed now
unfortunately but she was a she was i'm
gonna watch a lot of her talks um
actually instagram has that one thing on
reels where it's like
um
uh the delor it's dolores voice nobody
probably knows it's her but it's like
you came into this world to
learn how to manipulate energy and once
you learn how to manipulate energy you
can have anything you want the universe
there's nothing you can't have once you
learn how to do that and i'm like that's
dolores and i was thinking about dolores
um this beaut wonderful 80 some year old
woman that i watch her watch her her her
lectures of um talk about the fact that
you know
as this continuum exists
i don't want to have to come back in the
next life to learn this lesson seriously
though like it invites me it it there's
a sense of peace there because it
invites me to face the thing because
either that or i'm going to have to get
to 39 years old again next time around
to go here you are danica are you going
to figure it out this time yeah
yeah absolutely and i think all of that
comes from really the decision
if we believe that this is a meaningful
or meaningless universe
and so and if we think that it's
meaningful if we think that there's
purpose
behind
our actions and what's happening then we
can't really pick and choose what's
purposeful and what's not purposeful
like oh it was so purposeful when i got
this
book deal but it was so meaningless when
my marriage fell apart yeah when my kid
was upset or something like that and
when you take that even into just
relationship conflict the next time
you're within an argument with your
partner if you just ask that question if
this is on purpose
what could it be meaning what might we
be learning right now
yeah and that's just that changes things
it's just that it comes down to an
assumption of love of like yeah are we
is this all random and haphazard or
can we feel into that
orchestration that maybe this is
happening for a reason and if so why
whether our ego likes that answer or not
yeah yeah thank you that was well said a
meaningful or a meaningless
uh universe and to close with more words
from you the
the the the sentence we can't live as
soul mates if we don't know ourselves as
souls
and i think that's a good way to close
and i think that that point is really
beautiful adam and elisa thank you so
much for
um
bearing your soul
for doing the work and being able to
share it with others and inviting people
to
meet themselves at the level that
i think the universe has always been
hoping we do
well thank you for everything we love
you so much and we love your soul and i
don't know if you've seen this but
you're on the top of our book we your
your endorsements right there oh my god
whatever so yeah
i'll be sending this to you in the mail
thank you thank you thank you i have the
pdf
um
congratulations a labor of love but um
i always find that the the harder the
harder harder something is the more
meaningful it is and um as far as uh
when it's calling and it's in alignment
it's um that attrition leads to
really beautiful things and so thank you
guys yeah thank you thank you so much
it's a pleasure thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button